and also I think in a way reflects life
you know it's life is funny and dark at
the same time and it's rather odd the
way that we have to move you know tend
to push dramatic representations into
such strict genres I wanted to start
with Florence pastor Jenkins you you've
been somewhat less of a constant
presence in the last few years but this
is a major part in a major movie
opposite Meryl Streep what made you
decide to do this particular movie
what are you right that I am you're
right I was I had kind of moved on a bit
I was doing other things I was doing
politics and I seemed to have a child a
week and
so I was not I've not been very focused
on show business over the last few years
but then Stephen Frears who's a
supporter of hacked off the political
stuff I've been doing he just kept
saying calls to a film and I thought he
was just drunk and then he to my great
surprise sent me a script that was
genuinely funny and moving and I liked
the sort of slight grotesque element of
it and it had this extraordinary nuanced
complicated part for me which is
something I'm not accustomed to and so I
was you know and plus he's a classy
director and the small matter of Meryl
Streep you know it was a I had to do it
the the carrot the carrot forints Foster
Jenkins for those of you don't know is I
first encountered her name on a list of
the ten least likely celebrities an
heiress who filled concert halls
precisely because she could not sing a
note and you mentioned you very
self-deprecating about this the amount
of the level of nuance that this role
has but do you really feel that way
about a lot of your well I really don't
feel that way ok good I was just going
for a cheap laugh nobody Oh even it is a
complicated role because you can't quite
tell if he's if he's good or bad and I
liked that he doesn't fit into a easy
goodie baddie kind of category at least
for a lot of the film and I thought that
would be fun and yeah was Meryl Streep
what was she like I just picture her
Barrett being born onto the set with a
retinue of servants and you know perhaps
an entire team of people and you know is
she intense well there's no retinue
apart from big Roy who's have been her
makeup guy since 1974 or something you
know who's a
a great mine of fantastic showbiz
stories and bitchiness
and apart from him I didn't notice any
right in you at all but is she intense
well yes I mean I don't think you get to
be that brilliant without enormous
dedication so that that in itself is
alarming I mean not just the scale of
her talent but the scale of that it's
quite a new yorky thing actually I've
come across it in New York actors before
it's a real like acting czar kind of
quasi religion and you know for the
average English lovey who's you know
basically learn your lines and try not
to bump into the furniture dear it's
it's intimidating
I did actually want to ask you about
that the whole idea of preparation there
is a school of thought and I think it's
become more prevalent probably since
since the 70s when De Niro was coming up
that if you're going to play a cab
driver you go out and get a hack license
or if you're going to play a boxer you
train for a year so forth do you have
you ever done anything like that no but
and of course the traditional British
Way is to slightly sneer at that and
then everyone quotes the Laurence
Olivier Dustin Hoffman's story you know
Oh Marathon Man
yeah you know acting whatever it was but
I have found I will say this I think the
Americans are right and we're wrong when
it comes to film acting definitely
without a hundred percent because some
over the years doing productions where
you've got English actors and then a
couple of Americans you notice it very
much in rehearsal or the read-through
the English are giving it everything
lots of welly darling you know and and
then the American is mutters like this
and you think I'll come on you know and
actually I think they are dead right
because what they're doing is saving it
up for the moment you know weeks later
when there's actually filming the camera
and they're in close-up and because you
only have a finite resource of freshness
and unfortunately freshness is what the
camera wants more than anything and you
know it hates well-rehearsed repeating
of stuff and it loves something
absolutely minted in the moment and that
was one thing that Meryl was especially
surprisingly brilliant at is that every
take completely different completely
different performance whereas you know
most of us are thinking oh [ __ ]
I had a performance and I just give me
one more take to do it again and I don't
like him but in fact what's good about
her she's completely makes it up again I
was very impressed by that what was
you're working a relationship like did
you have any rapport that you worked out
any particular things that you had to
iron out anything
no it helped when I realized that she
couldn't see me at all
because she's I don't think I'm
revealing anything she wouldn't reveal
but she's good she's very short-sighted
but chooses she's not wearing glasses in
this film character thing and she
doesn't like to wear lenses because the
camera can pick them up so actually even
if you were Meryl Streep and I was Hugh
Grant I could be Denzel Washington and
she wouldn't
so you're just you're just an
impressionist blob of colored well I
don't know I thought I might be I think
but she definitely I mean it's not to
say she's acting in a vacuum because
she's listening very carefully
and you don't ever think she can't see
me but it's yeah let's let's travel on
the Wayback Machine for a second and let
me ask you how how did you become an
actor how did you decide to become an
actor well it was um it was a accident
really because I I liked acting I liked
Eileen I liked doing it at school and
showing off and all the classic you know
psychology of that but I didn't plan to
be an actor but when I was at university
there was a guy who was a graduate there
called Mike Hoffman who went on to make
films and he put together a amateur film
and said you know I need to act as Hugh
because I'd done plays at Oxford he said
would you act in it and I said I now
don't really think so and he said oh
come on come on Victoria Studds go be in
it who was a really hot student so I
said all right and and we did it and I
didn't think more about it and after
I've graduated in that summer I was off
to do at the end of the summer I was
gonna go into another degree at another
university we had a screening of this
film and very much to my surprise at the
end of it agent said do you want to be
an actor and I said it's very nice of
you but not really and then and then I
thought actually that would be I need
some money so I'll do that for a year
and then one year turned into 35 so you
weren't one of those one of those kids
who was doing constant pageants and
reciting poems and things for your
family or any of that sort of thing this
was yeah I did alas yeah yeah but that's
not quite the same as wanting to be a
professional actor my my recitations
were always surprising to my parents cuz
what I didn't know was that I had a
completely different accent at school
than I had at home because my school was
not contrary to
people think a posh school at all and my
parents for various reasons is not their
fault had posh accents I had a posh
accent at home but when I was apparently
reciting at school then they become and
listen it was good afternoon to smash
him up we were having to say psychic up
so yeah I grew up with two accents and
two personalities were you you were a
bit of an athlete weren't you in school
um well yeah I played rugby and I was
remarkably brave really I know I said
myself but only out of I was brave out
of cowardice because I found that I
spent the first couple of years of
voiding tattling and then I found that
hurt more than if you tackled with
incredible ferocity and violence so I
became a fierce tackler so you take you
taught yourself blood loss then yes
littleman excellent and I still like to
hurt people I'll try to keep that in
mind how you you went on to do you
probably a breakthrough I was trying to
think of what that would be I guess
Morris maybe yes James ivory who I just
had the pleasure of interviewing a
couple of weeks ago he still speaks very
highly of you that's very nice and you
shared the prize of the Venice Film
Festival with James trilby will be will
be for that for that for that
performance yes and that was wasn't that
the up to the next level after that for
you yes and then very quickly down from
that level what happened well I was a
bit of a slag and just accepted
everything that came along including
some quite dodgy mini series and things
like that
and I hadn't learnt a lesson that if you
if you've got a reputation for a second
of doing quality stuff you've got to
keep the quality up and so I that the
quality sync and I need to have another
boost too you know with four weddings to
make everything pick up again you you
made you made some really interesting
movies between those two though like
impromptu I see you're like oh god
please don't bring up Lee
have the white warm but I just did did
were there any of those that you enjoy
that you would watch again that you
would recommend well I think if I was
very drunk or smoked a lot of pot I
would definitely watch the lair of the
white world and that is the stoners
absolute favorite film which Ken Russell
and I play an RAF officer who I don't
know what I do I I I cut people in half
who turn into worms and things like that
and yeah I suppose I could watch that
for a laugh
but I I don't really watch anything I've
done very much you you began with Four
Weddings and a funeral two to cultivate
and have offered to you this persona
that we now think of as a Hugh Grant
sort of persona on screen but before
that I was so surprised to see that that
aspect of you come forth because in
movies like impromptu you were you were
the pursued you were you were more I
guess you would say I'm not certain I
wouldn't go so far as a passive but
you're definitely not Judy Davis is a
whirlwind in that yeah yeah she is she's
the man and I'm very much the innocent
little flower that she's trying to
deflower was that a case of just you
know I I try to ask actors this every
time I talk to them how does it happen
that you are known for a particular
thing and then there would be a phase of
your career where you're known for
another particular thing and then there
will be yet another and at all I always
wonder how much control do you have over
it how much foresight is there is there
a design or is it just cosmic forces
randomly well I think it's a bit of both
I mean with me the lovely thing about
Four Weddings coming along was that it
was comedic and I had the only thing I
felt I was remotely useful in in terms
of acting was if there was some jokes
around that's quite good at knowing
where they are and trying to bring them
out and I concurrent with that whole
career I'd had up till then doing films
and television
I'd had a comedy show with
to friends which was on my real source
of pride and passion and and so when I
went off to do these films which are
rather serious you know I put on my
serious face as best I could but really
I thought I'd be more comfortable with
few jokes around and so that was the
good thing about for weddings when okay
that's just that was I felt like I'm
more doing something that I can do which
other people can't do whereas if it's
deep dark Strindberg you know ray
Fiennes will do that better so to a
certain extent it's not typecasting it's
just doing what you're best at when we
were shooting for weddings in a funeral
or for that matter when you're working
on any film is there a point where you
think this could actually work where you
have a good feeling about it and you
don't think you're just being
unreasonably optimistic well I certainly
thought that when I read that script it
was a bizarrely brilliant script I
remember calling my agent and saying I
think there's been a mistake you sent me
a good script and and which happened one
more time in my career when they sent me
Jerry Maguire and they said yes sorry
there was a mistake that was meant to go
to Tom Cruise
so but with Four Weddings yet what I
thought the script was good and stood a
good chance but we were all pessimists
and when we cut the film together the
rough cut looked at it me Mike Newell
that producers we all thought Richard
Curtis all thought it was an abomination
and really wanted to emigrate and why
don't you think that we just just didn't
didn't like it was funny or clever or
interesting and and then they took it to
Santa Monica and had a screening and
everyone went mad for it and said it
just we were wrong and audiences were
right and that was that was the
beginning of what I think of his face
phase two yeah yeah yeah that's right
and then you were you're doing things
like nine months for a Hollywood studio
well I did oh yeah I suddenly had the
you know the world at my feet
bizarrely I'd have absolutely no one and
I took forever to choose something to do
and I remember driving my agents
absolutely insane because I don't really
want to do anything and then this
project of Christopher Columbus's came
along and and I did it and I very nearly
ruined it I bet it did pretty much ruin
it I mean he you know he's a genius
really mrs. Doubtfire and home alone on
those things he's a genius what he does
and there's brilliant people in that
film Julianne Moore and Tom Arnold and
all those people with whom Jeff Goldblum
and I just I don't know why I think I
panicked you know having been paid
20,000 pounds or whatever it was to do
four weddings a funeral if you suddenly
paid millions you think well I better
ramped up my performance by two hundred
times but all that means is you over act
critically which is what I did so I'm
always very apologetic to those people
right when you when you look back on
that period do you think are there are
there any parts of it that you would
save in terms of you yes your bomb it
the the midden the midden of the post
for weddings and funerals yes no some
good films well I did there was some
that I signed up for before
for weddings came out so an awfully big
adventure is a good film yes so directed
by Mike Newell and the Englishman he
went up a hill is a charming film and
well I liked I liked the thriller no one
else went to see it but I think extreme
measures I'm quite proud of no there's
plenty in there and of course Notting
Hill is you know people like that
Notting Hill is fascinating especially
if you watch it right after Four
Weddings and a funeral because I've
developed this sort of I guess I would
say a grand unifying theory of Hugh
Grant and one and one part of that is
one part of that is that starting at
some time in the mid 90s your films
start to seem like a autobiographical in
the sense that they're about there is
much about fame and responsibilities as
they are the story that they're telling
yeah sorry sorry to lay that on you
without warning but Notting Hill
particularly because the Julia Roberts
character in that movie is the person
who has his besieged by the paparazzi
can't have a moment's peace every move
she makes is scrutinized and you're
playing the average guy you're playing
the ordinary guy which is why she's
attracted to you but I wonder if you
weren't feeling some of the same things
that she was feeling it that her
character was feeling at that point in
your career well I suppose I had had
some experience of that yeah but I don't
want to put a pin in your theory but I
did oh please do whatever wasn't the
reason I did that for I did I did that
from just because what for the same
reason as any other film I've done is
literally because it's the best script
on the table at that moment and this one
happened to be Notting Hill it happened
to be with a brilliant premise I mean
you know you can sometimes tell with the
one-line pitch line and when it's you
know nobody Bookseller
falls in love with most famous woman in
the world it's great I want to see that
film instantly can I ask you a really
geeky question about that movie yes oh
good if you'd said no I don't know what
it would be there's a section in that
movie where after you can't be with
Julie Roberts anymore where they chart
the passage of one year and you're
walking through a marketplace and you
see the sea
changing how did you how was that seen
done well analog old-fashioned way the
you know with props guys with brain
machines and throwing snowflakes at you
there was no digital in that I I don't
think we had digital in 1998 or if it
was it was in its infancy I remember a
lot of polystyrene in my throat and
eyeballs I wanted to talk to you about
about a boy which is a film I gather
you're fond of as well yes this is a
movie that you correct me if I'm wrong
but didn't you acquire the rights to
that novel long before you were able
actually to make it was that true I
think I tried and then try DeNiro got
hold of it before you did or something
yes I think that's right De Niro had it
a bit but previous to that Ian softly
was going to make it and he didn't want
me when it was went into turnaround with
his version the lovely Weitz brothers
came on board and it was like it was
with with new line and yeah we set it up
completely differently and then new line
decided they didn't want it at the last
moment so I went to my old cozy friends
working title and that's how we made it
now this is not a funny haha movie all
of the time this movie and this is
something I feel like this might be one
of the kinds of films that you maybe as
a leading actor always on look out for
you have the character has more than one
layer to them and there are some there
are some challenges implicit that's not
just you know you can be funny but there
may be some things you don't know for
sure that you can do and yeah yeah well
it is it's a lovely place to be at least
for me it's very comfortable place to be
run as jokes as a dark and light notes
in the same place I was saying to you
backstage earlier apart from anything
else if the joke doesn't work you can
always pretend it was meant to be a
serious scene yeah in in those
geometries as there
and yeah it takes a bit debris just take
the pressure off the comedy it takes the
pressure off the it takes the heaviness
out of the serious bits so it's a it's a
it's a nice tone and it also I think in
a way reflects life you know it's life
is funny and dark at the same time and
it's rather odd the way that we have to
leave you know tend to push dramatic
representations into such a strict
genres do you do you ever wish that you
had been more of a sort of
stereotypically dramatic actor where
you're you know no no no no not really
because I said I'm sound like terrible
or cliche but I comedy is hard and it's
hard because really it's binary
it's either funny or it's not funny
people either go har-har or they don't
whereas with drama you're dealing in
infinite shades of grey and it's that's
actually quite relaxing it's true of
course you can be more moving or less
moving but there's something absolutely
terrifying about will they laugh or will
they not laugh and it can be down to
such tiny tiny things tiny increments or
performance tiny increments of camera
position editing the music you put
behind the scene I've known scenes which
gets huge laughs in previews and then
you experiment and you change that the
music that's on the jukebox in the
background on the bar and suddenly they
don't laugh again and it's it's very
delicate I'm fascinated by this because
there is a sense that we think of the we
think of the great films you think of
the series films we think of the dramas
and if you look at the types of films
that win awards the last I believe the
last movie to win best picture that was
basically a comedy was Annie Hall what
about that silent movie I was thinking
about that is that would you count that
as a comedy I can't remember really
think so but yeah I know what you mean
and I know what you mean and and why is
that
you know why is that why do we think
seriousness darkness equals quality why
is comedy nuts why is comedy not taken
seriously I guess is the question yeah
but I think people do it Marez and they
like it it's just for some reason we
have to applaud death and misery I I was
on the American Academy panel to
shortlist Best Foreign Language Film
this year and just after Christmas and
they put you in a basically a cinema for
five days and show you 15 films from
around the world and you're supposed to
reduce the list of five or seven or
delivers now and it about eight of them
were about the Holocaust because because
countries have worked out each country
gives one film and they've worked out
that is their best chance of getting a
nomination this is actually true yeah
there's something a little dispiriting
about that good though they were many of
them yes but comedies when when done
well stick with people yeah I think I
hope so and yeah I just keep making a
point it is it's not easy those things
are not easy light is quite difficult to
achieve
you know you've often been compared I
don't want to embarrass you but here we
are - Cary Grant yes yes
were you were you were you a fan of his
growing up did you draw anything from
him
no next question I mean when Four
Weddings came out people kept asking
that question mainly because I have the
same name and to be
I it was an embarrassing question
because to be honest I'm not very sinned
illiterate or at least I will certainly
wasn't then and I didn't really know
Cary Grant very well but since then I
have watched his stuff and of course
he's just a you know massive genius and
now I find the question here deeply
embarrassing yeah I withdraw it then
okay what what movie stars did you
admire growing up are there any that you
still look to his inspiration well it
didn't really work like that and I don't
remember being aspired well yeah okay
the ones I revered were not the kind of
actors that I can ever emulate because
we don't really work in precisely the
same kind of genre so be you know De
Niro and Pacino and it was Goodfellas
and The Godfather and Once Upon a Time
in America and we loved me and my
British friends we loved all that kind
of gangs and death and darkness but I
you know I say I've never been offered
one of those films and I've never really
understood why well you got to do Mickey
blue eyes yes I did I did maybe that's
why we made it yeah you had actually one
of the I wrote this down because I liked
it so much a quote about you in that
film from Kenneth Turan of the Los
Angeles Times he said he was reviewing
Mickey blue eyes and he said if Hugh
Grant had been on the Titanic fewer
lives would have been lost if he'd
accompanied Robert Scott to the South
Pole the explorer would have lived to be
100 that's how good Hugh Grant is at
rescuing doomed ventures well that's the
definition of mr. feelings because III
feel at this night he's being nice about
me as an actor but I feel sad as a
producer of that film and anyway that
film has I personally feel it has has
many flaws but it also has two or three
scenes which are still make me laugh to
this day it's I'm actually laughing just
thinking about it because I think if you
put like you know the word the phrase
high concept is bandied about a lot but
I feel like Hugh Grant in an American
gangster film that's about as high
content well that was that was the joke
you know yes and it's and it never gets
old for me
yeah good but you have played these
sorts of parts once in a while that I
think are those more of those
transformational parts like Cloud Atlas
yeah which I can only imagine what that
experience was like replaying characters
across multiple time zone yeah heavy
makeup in some cases yeah can you tell
me a little bit about that well just
that during this phase of really not
doing very many films occasionally
oddities come up that are just too
fascinating to turn down and this one
which housekeeper others now sisters in
are came up with this project and wanted
me to place six baddies in six different
time zones and it was so fascinating
actually was five and I went to meet him
and I I said I'd do it if you give me a
sixth one there was there was a role
that I really liked and they gave it to
me and I kind of enjoyed it I didn't
realize what prosthetic makeup meant I
didn't enjoy sitting in makeup for six
hours every day having plastic applied
to my face but I thought in five of the
roles I was pretty good and in one of
them I was shocking I thought was very
bad as the cannibal in the
post-apocalyptic world I actually like
that
oh good I thought it was a I imagine
this is what you would have been like in
a Mad Max film yeah maybe maybe but I'd
sort of assumed I could do it and then I
remember standing on a mountaintop with
no hair and tattoos and I supposed to
lick my lips ready to eat a human being
and I thought I can't do this I need a
witty line here
one of them watch house keys kept saying
come on man more like a panther yeah
you're really hungry it's good it's good
to motivate your actors I suppose yeah
yes let me I wanted to throw out just a
few general questions just to see what
you might have to say about them what is
your comfort food film what is the film
that you watch when you cannot decide
what else to watch Goodfellas I think
there's any way that there are very few
films I watch more than once and they're
all tend to be - yeah to do with
organized crime what member of your
family probably most influenced you as
an actor
oh my mom the rest of them can't act at
all
uh-uh
well my mum was a was a good mimic she
did good funny voices and yeah so if I
any ability I have comes from her for
sure
and got me into a lot of trouble at
school because I was endlessly
imitating teachers and things when
you're when your kids are old enough to
appreciate the fact that daddy is in a
movie what movie do you show them first
I can't get them interested in any of my
stuff I chain them to chairs and try and
show them they've got shocking taste
they want to watch farm and Sam for
Christ's sake well I don't think they
they they don't I think they think that
everyone's daddy's on the side of buses
you know they don't
if you could save one of your movies the
negative of one of your movies from a
fire low dipping well this is yeah I
actually accept for Florence Fosters
well it would be that or about a boy but
then I yeah would be one of those too
but it would I suppose we'd have to go
with about a boy because that has a
negative whereas I think we have time
for just a couple of questions if you if
you're out of that yeah anybody I hear
we get to see you dance in this film and
I'm just curious and I was curious after
seeing me I'm the opposite of Meryl uh
do you ever ad-lib when you do these
dances the dances yes uh yeah yes very
much so I pride myself on my
choreography yeah
I claim that in music and lyrics I
invented that dance that became a
sensation all over the Far East what was
it called some know something man what
was it what he was doing what what
gangman I invented gangman style in
music Ella yeah sorry to jump in on this
mr. grant mr. Curtis tells me that
during Love Actually when you do your
improvise he'll dance yeah that was not
a fun initially a fun experience can you
tell us a little bit about that well
only that he kept wanting me to rehearse
it and I was too frightened to I kept
making excuses and it was never a
Hurston tone and we shot it and then yes
that's not easy you know well it's not
easy at 7:00 in the morning if you're a
cross middle-aged Englishman suddenly
start wiggling your ass in front of her
stone-cold sober you know it was note so
it's an appalling experience actually
same movie um we used to watch when we
were kids we had white Christmas every
Christmas was the movie we all sat down
as a family now we sit down and watch
Love Actually do you think it's a well
the audience obviously thinks it's a
very worthy successor how do you feel
that's very nice
and I mean uh uh what horrifies me about
Love Actually is how good Collins story
is and I never liked anything good to
happen to Colin and but the last time I
watched that film III found his story
profoundly moving I might have shed a
tear my friend they were noticing that
almost every English actor we Revere has
been in one of the Harry Potter movies
yet was that a conscious thing or it
just happened well I was they did come
to me about one part in one film and I
can't honestly remember why I turned it
down well actually I can and I can
remember it I can't remember the part
then I can't we'll go for a drink I tell
you
we are actually featuring after New York
are doing a rooftop screening of two
weeks notice and I would ask there's an
amazing chemistry between you and Sandra
Bullock it looked like it was a lot of
fun was it actually fun or was that the
best acting you've ever done it's
unquestionably marvelous acting but no
oddly enough you're right I adored
Bullock we had a lovely time and yes I
miss her really I remember getting back
from the world tour of publicizing that
film and walking around my kitchen
thinking I'm sad I miss I miss sandy
she's you know I don't if you ever had a
hip but she's a she's a laughs she's not
British what oh no she's a filthy German
yeah has more reason to have her happy
I saw Florence last week and what I
really loved is your expression while
she's singing how hard was that - did
you ever crack up and what was your
first impression on hearing her voice
well you're right it is it is
irresistible
funny watch what mouth does and she had
a kind of silly ometer for her her bad
singing and sometimes she'd set it at
one and sometimes very often actually
when she wasn't on camera I think almost
deliberately to make us all laugh were
the ones who were on camera she'd turn
it up to 11 or 12 and I did struggle it
was a scene in that film where I have to
be very fierce to the people who are
laughing at her at a concert and kind of
give them hard stares and tell them off
but in fact I am absolutely killing
myself laughing and son it was a real
struggle
what do you thank the great Hugh Grant
and Matt Zoller Seitz
and I'm going to lead you offstage who
can't Matt's on site thank you very much
you're very nice thank you
at the same time if you're doing stuff
that's a little bit more technical a
little bit more visually flaring like
Sherlock is and obviously Star Trek and
and very much smog in mocap you kind of
have to go the distance of understanding
it in order not to hurt yourself
primarily and also just to make it work
make the shot work make the moment work
we were in a world where broadchurch had
been had already been a sort of
international thing and with GracePoint
we set out very consciously to tell the
same story because that you know someone
did the math or the math sorry